[Musique]
gabriel matzneff qui est en face de vous
si la vraie vie est un professeur quand
même d'éducation sexuelle c'est quand
même c'est quand il ya deux matches
c'est parce que il donne volontiers des
cours et en payant de sa personne et ce
qui est vrai c'est que vous aimez ça se
voit très bien mais j'en à vous aimer
séduire vous aimez surtout d'initier
j'aime séduire parce que comme vient le
dire très justement monsieur il n'ya que
lorsque l'on aime que l'ont été mais que
faire l'amour devient une aventure
extraordinaire et que l'amour sans amour
notamment l'amour mercenaires l'amour
vénal est une évidemment ne peut être
jamais qu'une caricature de l'amour
entre deux êtres qui s'aiment mais
j'aime séduire vous savez j'ai été il ya
une partie théologique dans dans dans le
livre de nationale stagne à rang j'ai
été mariée et dans l'église orthodoxe ça
s'appelle le sacrement de l'amour mais
j'avais le sacrement l'amour et c'est
une hyène très belle théologie du
mariage dans l'église orthodoxe et de la
fidélité et quand je me suis marié je
suis pas mariée pour divorcer trois ans
après comme je lé fais j'aime me suis
mariée pour pour pour la pour la vie et
parce que je pensais jamais que ça que
je cesserai de mais lorsqu'on aime
quelqu'un on peut même pas imaginer
qu'on va cessé de l'aimer
et puis il faut beaucoup de vigilance il
faut beaucoup de vigilance et je n'ai
pas été vigilant et je me suis mal
conduit et ça a été à la destruction
et effectivement le livre qui paraît
enfin ces jours ci la mise à mort des
composés c'est celui non pas de la
période
seulement mariage et c'est une période
beaucoup plus récente d'une période
assez disons cazanove est ce que je
dirai plus dans la préface jeudi dans
jeunesse mais ce n'est pas tout à fait
juste parce que don juan
c'est quelqu'un qui ne souffre pas qui
n'aime personne il séduit mais il
accumule les rencontres ils couchent un
soir avec une femme ne sait même pas le
prénom puis le lendemain il la quitte
il souffre pas il est il est d'un pas
vide il est insensible tandis que moi je
je suis je suis malheureux je suis
jaloux lorsqu'on me plaque je souffre je
suis passionnément amoureuse j'ai tout
plaide est fabula pourquoi vous êtes
vous spécialiser dans les lycéennes et
les mines est au dessus de 20 ans on
voit que ça ne vous intéresse plus mon
cher c'est la réciprocité aussi qui est
vrai je n'ai jamais eu aucun succès
auprès des femmes de 25 30 et plus des
femmes installées dans la vie avec
denise barry et catherine
hermary-vieille vraiment vous pouvez je
ne pense pas qu'elle pourrait tomber
amoureuse de moi
en revanche lorsque dans une société
brillante ya une petite jeune fille qui
passe son bac et à qui personne note la
parole parce que les grandes personnes
s'intéressent pas vraiment adolescents
ils font la grimace qu'elles aient
toutes faites vous en êtes vous de vos
études et puis une fois qu'on a posé la
question et bien cette jeune fille ça
sera la seule qui après me dira me
passera voici mon téléphone je ne sais
pas c'est comme ça que ça se passe dans
la vie dit peut rien et puis j'aime bien
j'aime bien aussi et je trouve que quand
on a dans sa vie quelqu'un qui n'est pas
encore durci par la vie une femme qui a
déjà eu beaucoup d'hommes dans sa vie
beaucoup de désillusions parce que comme
les hommes sont en général soit des
égoïsmes des lâches
les femmes ne peuvent que se durcir
n'est ce pas et donc je préfère avoir
dans la vie des gens qui n'ont pas
encore durci qui sont plus gentils une
fille de très jeunes et plutôt plus
gentille
même si elle devient très très vite
hystérique et aussi folk quand elle sera
plus âgées mais elle est quand même
plutôt plus gentil que des femmes oui
mais alors pourquoi les collectionner
autant mais je prends de votre livre
qu'elle bouscule adam apporté dans mon
lit un peu plus loin on reste mon lit a
déjà plage affiche complet un peu plus
loin je suis archi comble plus loin j'ai
présentement 12 maîtresse régulière
je dois honorer doux et bon jeu des
ennemis qui vous connaissent qu'ils
disent que c'est vous d'inventer rien
non c'est un examen
j'ai une écurie de jeunes amants c'est à
dire seulement de leur apprendre qu'il
faut éviter le sida ou qu'il faut éviter
oui ça se peut avoir un moment il on
vous en parle beaucoup aussi
oui alors non mais c'est très bien joué
oui tout à fait d'accord avec avec la
partie que vous avez écrite parce que
c'est vrai que et là je reviens quand
même à ma surprise entre ce que vous
êtes et ce qu'il ya dans le livre parce
que quand on vous voit on se dise c'est
lumineux mais ce que j'ai lu dans le
livre c'est plutôt une conception de
l'amour s'est installé et je pense pas
que ce soit ça du tout qui fasse rêver
et qu en fait je crois que si on a à
nouveau envie de fidélité c'est dans sa
dimension aventure que j'ai retrouvé un
peu en filigrane et je suis d'autant
plus étonné que ce n'est pas ce que vous
êtes
est ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
et fondamental c'est que c'est fou
infidélité c'est pour ça qu'elle rend
possible le la composante passionnel de
l'amour parce que si la fidélité allait
de soi il n'y aurait plus aucun élément
passionnel c'est quelque chose qui
viendraient automatiquement
et si bien que ce serait un amour
uniquement élaboré ça me tracassait
penser qu'on puisse et éliminer la
maladie
en définitive on transgresse e
l'intimité de l'autre on transgresse
le jardin secret de l'autre on
transgresse la durée qu'on vend des
vêtements dit c'est une aventure à haut
risque sont colossaux tant qu'avocat et
surtout la maladie de l'amour la maladie
contre l'amour c'est l'habitude regardée
actuellement la perte de dynamisme dans
l'est dans la sexualité dans les 400
interview qu'on a posés qu'est ce qui
passe en premier c'est la tendresse la
fidélité et puis prof la sexualité passe
en troisième plan parce que c'est devenu
banal
autrement dit tant qu'il n'y a pas un
certain espace entre l'immédiat la
satisfaction on perd le temps du désir
si bien que c'est en riant que je dis
nous pensons qu'il ya que les amoureux
pour bien faire l'amour
oui pourquoi vous êtes profession d une
question sexuelle
[Rires]
j'aimerais mieux qu'on dise d'éducation
sexuelle et amoureuse
oui d'accord mais sinon professeurs non
mais intervient dans des écoles où ils
se racontent les parents et les enfants
et je trouve ça merveilleux et
maintenant elle fait tout cas idées
ensemble à vous mais bien où je te dire
au début je le faisais passer tes
étudiants en médecine qu'on me demandait
de venir expliquer ça qu'ensuite avec le
travail original danese a pris le relais
et depuis que nous sommes à la retraite
savait où nous sommes enfin marié 7000
laitiers il y avait les enfants et
depuis quarante et quelques années on
attendait ce moment là et ça y est c'est
la victoire
non c'est sa victoire elle était temps
de donner envie région de prendre leur
retraite avant l'âge c'est bien alors
gabriel matzneff qui est en face de vous
si un vrai d'état professeur quand même
d'éducation sexuelle c'est quand même si
les ouvriers de maths c'est parce que il
donne volontiers des cours et en payant
de sa personne et ce qui est vrai c'est
que vous aimez ça se voit très bien mais
j'en à vous aimer séduire vous aimez
surtout d'initier j'aime séduire parce
que comme bien le dire très justement
monsieur il n'ya que lorsque l'on aime
que l'ont été mais que faire l'amour
devient une aventure extraordinaire et
que l'amour sans amour notamment l amour
mercenaires l'amour vénal est une
évidemment elle ne peut être jamais
qu'une caricature de l'amour entre deux
êtres qui s'aiment mais j'aime c'est
dire vous savez j'ai été il ya une
partie théologique dans dans dans le
livre de national tan nara
j'ai été mariée et dans l'église
orthodoxe
ça s'appelle le sacrement de l'amour le
majeur est le sacrement l'amour et c'est
une ya une très belle théologie du
mariage dans l'église orthodoxe et de la
fidélité et quand je me suis marié je
suis pas mariée pour divorcer trois ans
après comme je lé fais j'aime me suis
mariée pour pour pour la pour la vie et
parce que je pensais jamais que ça que
je cesserai de mais lorsqu'on aime
quelqu'un on peut même pas imaginer
qu'on va cessé de l'aimer
et puis il faut beaucoup de vigilance il
faut beaucoup de vigilance et je n'ai
pas été vigilant et je me suis mal
conduit et ça a été à la destruction
et effectivement le livre qui paraît
enfin ces jours ci la maison pour
décomposer c'est celui non pas de la
période
seulement mariage c'est une période
beaucoup plus récente d'une période
assez disons cazanove est ce que je
dirai plus dans la préface jeudi
donjuanesque mais ce n'est pas tout à
fait juste parce que don juan
c'est quelqu'un qui ne souffre pas qu'il
n'aime personne il séduit mais il
accumule les rencontres il est couché un
soir avec une fan on ne sait même pas le
prénom puis le lendemain il la quitte
il ne souffre pas il est il n' a pas
vide il est insensible tandis que moi je
je suis je suis malheureux je suis
jaloux lorsqu'on me plaque je souffre je
suis passionnément amoureux j'ai toutes
les formules alors pourquoi vous êtes
vous spécialiser dans les lycéennes et
les mines est au dessus de 20 ans on
voit que ça ne vous intéresse plus mon
cher c'est la réciprocité aussi qui est
vrai je n'ai jamais eu aucun succès
auprès des femmes de 25 30 et plus des
femmes installées dans la vie avec
denise barry à catherine hermary vieille
vraiment vous pouvez je ne pense pas
qu'elle pourrait tomber amoureuse de moi
en revanche lorsque dans une société
brillante et une petite jeune fille qui
passe son bac et à qui personne note la
parole parce que les grandes personnes
s'intéressent pas vraiment adolescents
ils font la grimace qu'elles aient
toutes faites vous en êtes vous de vos
études et penny faire qu'on a posé la
question et bien cette jeune fille ça
sera la seule qui après me dira me
passera voici mon téléphone je ne sais
pas c'est comme ça que ça se passe dans
la vie il peut rien et puis j'aime bien
j'aime bien aussi et je trouve que quand
on a dans sa vie quelqu'un qui n'est pas
encore durci par la vie une femme qui a
déjà eu beaucoup d'hommes dans sa vie
beaucoup d illusions parce que comme les
hommes sont en général soit des égoïsmes
des lâches
les femmes ne peuvent que se durcir
n'est ce pas et donc je préfère avoir
dans la vie des gens qui n'ont pas
encore durci qui sont plus gentils les
filles de fred jeune et plutôt plus
gentille
même si elle devient très très vite
hystérique aussi folk quand elle sera
plus âgées mais elle est quand même
plutôt plus gentil que des femmes oui
mais alors pourquoi les collectionner
autant mais je prends de votre libre
qu'elle bouscule adam apporté dans mon
lit un peu plus loin on reste mon lit a
déjà plage affiche complet à plus loin
je suis archi comble plus loin j'ai
présentement 12 maîtresse régulière
je dois honorer doux et bon jeu des amis
qui vous connaissent qu'ils disent que
c'est vous d'inventer rien on s'est tapé
exane
j'ai une écurie de jeune amante c'était
on voit votre vie c'est incroyable il ya
dire que alors vous devez mentir le
téléphone pour pas qu'elle se
rencontrent vous faites l'amour le matin
l'après midi le soir sans des chronos
mais en fait il y a quand même ses
percées film sentions pas
interchangeables maryja bête
anne marie laurence marie agnès qui sent
la existent elles existent d'ailleurs
presque comme des personnages de romans
je veux dire elles ont leur caractère
elles ont leur tempérament elles sont
les unes sont complets sont pleines de
drôlerie marie-elisabeth à qui le livre
est dédié une fille pleine d'esprit que
m'envoie dans la figure des vérités et
que je note avec des listes parce
qu'elles sont vraiment justes et et
spirituelle et ce sont des liaisons
durable e marie zabeth gelé connu quand
elle avait 15 ans la haye la nana 20 ou
22 candidats se livrent elle est
toujours dans ma vie c'est pas des
filles d'une nuit
c'est durable et je souffre de ne pas
j'aimerais j'ai la nostalgie de la
fidélité d'ailleurs je le dis à
plusieurs reprises en ce libre que je
suis vous êtes quand même un
collectionneur de minettes et forêts est
alors par exemple vous faites des bilans
de temps en temps une forme éblouissante
donc et mes amours en témoigne la
conquête en trois jours consécutifs de
trois inconnus dont deux vierge marie
agnès mode et 7 brigitte s avec qui j'ai
fait l'amour toute les façon quasi sans
interruption un peu plus loin
récapitulons depuis mon retour en israël
j'ai fait la gouaille pascal mary
elizabeth elisabeth agnès denys florence
haute brigitte s pascal b marie agnès
marie laurence agnès m'a plaqué et avec
elisabeth cette tribu avait en vain
jouant quatre nouvelles maîtresses au
brigitte pascal b marie laure et je me
disais est ce que la question est un
petit peu vulgaire mais est-ce que vous
baisez pour votre journal aussi m'aider
à ce que parce que plus il y aura de
maîtrise plus ratage absolument pas non
vous savez je tiens mon carnet comme ça
d'une manière c'est pas un journal que
j'écris le soir sur mon bureau cinq
années que j'écris en marchant très
flash comme ça une écriture un peu
polaroïd et
donc ce sont des notations je note pour
fixer le moment qui passe parce que je
sais c'est le sens du livre c'est les
vers de baudelaire qui ont donné mon
titre d'ailleurs si amour d composé et
écrit au masculin je signale aux
puristes c'est parce que baudelaire
décrire masculin alors ô ma beauté dit à
la vermine qui vous mangera de baisers
que j'ai gardé la forme et l'essence
divine de mes amours décomposer et c'est
parce que je veux lutter contre l'oubli
j'ai horreur de l'oubli j'ai horreur des
gens qui tournent la page qui renie des
êtres ils ont aimé qu'ils qui affecte de
ne pas se souvenir de tout ce qu'ils ont
vécu que moi je note j'ai la mémoire
pour les autres notamment pour les
personnes qui m'ont aimée et qui pour m
avoir remis aujourd'hui alors je note
c'est une impression de vaincre la mort
c'est une lettre une illusion un stack
narac est-ce que vos soldats de la
pression de continuer à huis clos de
sartre parce que si vraiment on était
obligé un jour d'épouser votre
personnage avec la faible constitution
qui sont décrits un autre vous imaginez
de la prolongation infernal que cela
représenterait cet effarant dans huis
clos certains disent nous sommes comme
des chevaux de bois
il ya un aspect un peu circulaire dans
deux dans vos deux années là de
confidences tous les jours ça recommence
tous les jours ça recommence
et il faut prêter de donner de sa
personne oui mais ça lui plaît beaucoup
mais je ne dis pas je dis que c'est ça
me plaît mais parfois parfois je suis
passé par le livre d'un homme heureux
c'est le livre d'un homme souvent dire
finalement assez seul qui je parle
souvent de suicide de désespoir c'est
pas le livre d'un type qui est enfin moi
quelqu'un qui ne se pose aucune question
en tout cas oui mon panier vous êtes
écrivain donc je vous décrivais se pose
quand même des questions c'est évident
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya oui denise
bombardier
écoutez moi je crois que je vis
actuellement sur une autre planète
parce que j'arrive d'un continent où un
certain nombre de choses auxquelles on
croit
nous sommes à la fin du xxème siècle
nous défendons les droits de la personne
les droits la dignité le droit à
l'intégrité des personnes est une des
choses que l'on défend maintenant parce
qu'une chape du droit des enfants
c'est le droit des enfants et les jeunes
à être des jeunes et on les protège moi
monsieur matzneff me semble pitoyable ce
que je ne comprends pas
et que dans ce pays et le comprends
parce que la littérature à une sorte
d'aura ici c'est que dans ce pays la
littérature entre guillemets sert
d'alibi à ce genre de confidences parce
que ce que nous raconte monsieur
matzneff dans un livre qui quitteraient
en milieu parce que parce que la
répétition est extrêmement ennuyeuse de
lille finit par le tombé des mains c'est
madame qu'est ce qu'on va devenir
agressive comme ça mais si ma jeunesse
nous racontent qu'ils se donnent mise
des petites filles de 14 ans 15 ans que
ces petites filles sont folles de lui on
sait bien que des petit fils filles
peuvent être folle d'un monsieur qui a
une certaine aura littéraire d'ailleurs
on sait que les vieux monsieur attire
les petits enfants avec des bonbons
monsieur matzneff lui les attire avec sa
réputation mais ce que l'on sait aussi
c'est que ces petites filles
ce que l'on ne sait pas c'est comment
ces petites filles de 14 ou 15 ans n'est
ce pas qui ont été non seulement séduite
mais qui ont subi ce que l'on appelle
dans les rapports entre des adultes et
les jeunes un abus de pouvoir comment
s'en sortent tels ces petites filles
après coup moi je crois que c'est petit
fils à son son flétri et la plupart
d'entre elles laiterie peut-être pour le
restant de leurs jours
tout ça semble semble bien sûr mais tout
ça est enveloppé bien sûr mais je crois
effectivement que quand on parle quand
on veut dénoncer l'apartheid quelque
part quand on veut dénoncer la torture
ailleurs quand on veut dénoncer la
violation des droits des gens et à la
fin du xxème siècle quand je dis on en
est rendu là je crois qu'on ne peut pas
défendre ça et moi je ne comprends pas
comment on peut publier du chère madame
heureusement pour vous je suis un homme
courtois parce que vraiment je trouve
insensé de parler d'eux comme vous venez
de le faire que vous trouvez vous n'avez
pas lu mon livre vous l'avez feuilleter
dans ce livre il ya des rencontres
d'amour de séduction réciproque
je n'ai je ne suis pas du tout je suis
le contraire d'un macho d'un type qui
force qui que ce soit faire quoi que ce
soit et ce sont je me permets de vous
rappeler d amour durable
toutes les jeunes personnes qui sont là
sont restés dans ma vie et mon aimé
peut-être certaines même encore pendant
de très nombreuses années et vous
insistez il y as qu'il ya beaucoup la
plupart de ces jeunes filles d'ailleurs
un emploi pas une jeune fille de 14 ans
il ya des jeunes filles qu'il y en a que
deux ou trois ans qui sont tout à fait
l'âge de
des amours elle tombe sur un homme qui
n'est pas un monstre de leader qui est
relativement les traits qui est un assez
bien élevé qui peut être très gentil et
qui peut-être les rend très heureuse et
je vous interdit de porter des jugements
de ce genre de jugement
d'abord parce qu'un livre c'est une
écriture c'est un ton c'est un univers
je suis est donc d'abord portant un
jugement sur un livre d'abord savoir si
cette année d'un écrivain si c'est un
beau livre on ne peut pas ne peut pas
servir des solistes lui même à la
littérature
il n'y a pas de limite si monsieur
matzneff était plutôt un employé anonyme
de n'importe quelle société
je crois qu'ils auraient des comptes à
rendre avec la justice absolument alors
forcément ça devient absolument et quel
est votre avis là-dessus moi je reste
impressionné par l'aliénation ce que
représente mais il ya une sorte de
fascination et un aspect démoniaque
mais que dans lequel il ya un certain
plaisir vraisemblablement mais ses
filles
on ne peut pas les empêcher de subir une
certaine fascination et j'avoue que
comme vous je suis très impressionné
ça rejoint quelque chose de très grave
comme que comme vous en france
ces choses-là se disent son permis enfin
sont permises sont tolérées et que même
pas que c'est la france maintenant je
vois que c'est un certain milieu
parisien théâtre peut avoir l'air de
désendettement général on trouve sympa
sinon le libéral et je crois qu'aucun
pays n'est qu' aucun pays civilisé je
sais pas si vous avez lu notre livre
mais c'est une chose que je dis dans la
conclusion je tue étonné de voir que on
descend les droits de l'homme à tout
prix et qu'on ne défend pas les amours
fidèles alors que vous y tromper dans un
contrat on va en prison et tromper son
mari sait c'est drôle il se trouve que
c'est dommage qu'on dise comme ça en
france
oui votre avis qui a pu m'arriver oui
mais surtout le g2 sur tout et à
l'impression de quelqu'un de malheureux
de quelqu'un qui se posaient des
questions très profonde sur lui-même
mais je pense que c'est pas à livre de
bonheur mais c'est un livre qui pose de
l'interrogation sur l'auteur aussi sur
ce qu'ils recherchent ceux qui
l'espèrent de sa vie et j'ai trouvé huit
morts six suisses et un livre où il ya
une grande tristesse et une grande
tristesse qui est comme un fils qui
tisse une étoffe peut-être de joie de
rencontre mais les fils qui tease cette
étoffe sont des fils de crise et je lui
ai donné ma snes terminé conclusion
écouter et lorsqu'on est attaquée d'une
façon aussi aussi j'veux dire aussi
injuste n'est ce pas c'est très
difficile de se défendre jeudi dans ses
livres c'est une période je le journal
jaurégui des périodes de grande fidélité
dans la vie de constance et où
effectivement j'étais beaucoup plus
heureux que dans ces périodes de
dispersion cazanove esque mais les
termes qu'a employé ma voisine de droite
je les trouve inadmissible je les trouve
injuste surtout et il prouve qu'il n'a
vraiment pas lu mon livre de la
feuilleter n'est ce pas et quand j'écris
au cours de ces 48 heures j'ai mesuré
l'absurdité lorum à dispersion amoureuse
moralement c'est honteux
minable et sensuellement c'est le
contraire de ce qu'il faut faire
j'étais cent fois mille fois plus
heureux que je me suis aujourd'hui
à l'époque j'étais fidèle à francesca le
faisait l'amour qu'avec qu'elle à notre
rythme
intime et passionné et on pourrait
trouver bien des passages comme ça dans
ce livre c'est un livre véridique c'est
un journal dégagement fait pas de tort
justement en faisant quand même
dans ce livre des palmarès de temps
j'entends
je note de manger sans penser je note
oui je me fais du tort sans doute
peut-être que pour faire plaisir à
madame je me tire une balle dans la tête
sur un public sur cette scène n'est ce
pas comme mishima se suicider en public
je ne le ferai pas mais vraiment je
trouve que ce n'est pas extrêmement très
honorable sur madame de de profiter
d'une émission en direct pour venir
insulter un écrivain et d'une manière
aussi légères et aussi grossière c'est
tout ce que je puis dire cela dit c'est
le public qui lira et si ce livre est
encore lui dans x années
ça sera grâce à son écriture à son style
parce qu'un écrivain c'est d'abord une
écriture et avant de porter des
jugements moraux sur un livre on apporte
d'abord des jugements esthétiques et
artistiques
on ne dit pas assez il faudrait
peut-être le rappelait aussi ici dans
cette émission littéraire
voilà on termine la polémique là-dessus
bien
[Musique]